is texas senator ted cruz is with us
senator you know we go from court
packing to leaking uh
you know draft uh possible drafts of a
decision now to doxing the homes of
supreme court justices only an effort to
harass intimidate
these justices i'm not sure how they're
going to be able to move back to the
neighborhood and move back home
uh now that this effort is is going full
force what shocks me even more than
anything though is that joe biden has
basically put a seal of approval on it
and saying well people are free to
protest anywhere they want uh i would
think that he'd be a little more prudent
and understand the danger of of people
showing up at the homes of elected
officials or judges or anybody that
works in government for that matter
well sean you're exactly right what
we're seeing these images
are the latest manifestation of just how
extreme just how radical the democratic
party is getting this democratic party
today joe biden has handed the agenda
over to the socialists and not just the
socialists this is now the marxist this
is now the communist today's democrat
party believes in violence they believe
in mob rule they believe in intimidation
just like marxists and communists
they're willing to burn our institutions
to the ground to get what they want this
leak from the court is fundamentally
destructive to the supreme court of the
united states to the rule of law and to
our constitution and none of these
democrats care joe biden won't condemn
it the white house won't condemn the
leak instead they sit back and say oh
isn't that interesting you're just
passionate as nancy pelosi says is jen
saki said listen
these thugs
have no business at the private homes
of any government officials these
supreme court justices or anyone else
these thugs who dox the justices should
be embarrassed and a shame and by the
way these are the same thugs that are
firebombing
pro-life outlets these are the same
thugs that are going into churches
disturbing churches they hate faith they
hate god they hate the catholic church
and it is disgusting
to see
joe biden and the entirety of the
democratic party turn a blind eye what
we're seeing sean
is a replay of 2020 a replay of the
black lives matter and the antifa riots
and in this instance once again they're
putting politics above everything else
including people's lives and and these
radicals are inviting violence directed
at our judiciary and directed at the
rule of law so they're bullying trying
to intimidate these justices let's go
back to the summer of 2020 where we had
over 574 rights we had dozens of dead
americans thousands of injured cops
billions of dollars in property damage
okay we know that took place not only
were they silent there were many people
like kamala harris that actually offered
moral support for these groups and and
the bail fund and the defund dismantle
effort uh then january 6 happens uh
donald trump says many of you will
peacefully patriotically march to the
capitol so your voices will be heard
that's the one riot that they only want
to focus on
now they're okay with sending and
allowing or proving of people going to
the homes and doxing the homes of
these justices
why the selective moral outrage and why
the silence of people that seem so
outraged over the one riot but ignore
the 574 other riots and ignore the
doxing i'm trying to understand their
logic
well it's all politics for them the ends
justify the means and it's complete
hypocrisy you see this in in the
corporate media you see this among
democrats
on january 6 of 2021 you had tens of
thousands of people peacefully
protesting and yet the corporate media
and democrats slandered them with the
made-up term insurrectionist and yet
in this instance that they are not
willing to call off their goons
even now even now as this has the
potential to escalate and escalate
further and and you know part of it is
the extreme left they know their ideas
are unpopular when it comes to abortion
today's democratic party has gotten so
radical
they support unlimited abortion on
demand up until the moment of birth
with taxpayer funding and no parental
consent and no parental notification
sean do you know the latest polling
shows that just six percent of americans
support unlimited abortion on demand
right up until the moment of birth the
reason democrats are freaking out is
they can't actually convince their
fellow citizens through the democratic
process to adopt their extreme radical
views so instead they want to use brute
force and in this instance they want to
use violence listen if these guys want
to protest great go to the public square
go to the mall
go in front of the supreme court there
have been protesters in front of the
supreme court from the time it was built
all of that is legitimate but they're
not looking for
peaceful speech they're looking for
threats they're looking for intimidation
they're looking for targeting the kids
of the justices and that is grotesque
every and you know just this week we saw
the washington post do this glowing hey
geography of this one
protester this woman who is protesting
her neighbor brett kavanaugh i mean it
is
shameful
and and this is where today's democrat
party is you know what it is
they are afraid of november because they
know the voters are going to throw them
out on their rear ends there are states
right now and this is a big lie the big
myth that if rose overturned that
abortion will become illegal in america
no it will not the states will decide
because roe was bad law in my from my
perspective you're the law uh student
one of uh alan dershowitz's best in his
own words
and
basically what they did in the case of
roe is they granted a right not granted
in the constitution and so that would i
would argue uh trigger the tenth
amendment and then rather than
go forward and give that right to
individuals they basically send it back
to the states new york california new
jersey there are a whole bunch of states
that allow abortion up until you know
the hour before birth for crying out
loud that will still continue in some
states won't it so abortion's not going
anywhere
yeah no that's that's right and and if
you look at our nation's history for the
first 185 years of our nation's history
abortion was decided by elected
legislators primarily at the state level
and and listen we all recognize that
abortion is an issue that is deeply
emotional it's personal people feel very
strongly and have sharply divided views
what happened in 1973 when roe versus
wade was handed down
was seven unelected lawyers in black
robes said to the american people you
pesky voters your views don't matter we
know better than you do we are
philosopher kings and we are going to
decree the rule and i'll tell you that
ruling it was wrong the day it was
issued it's been wrong every day since
then
but that ruling produced enormous anger
enormous division because when people
disagree and feel strongly about it if
the democratic process is available to
them you can go and make the case to
your fellow citizens and you can argue
for it but with roe the court said no we
know better than you do if roe is in
fact overturned and i pray that it is
the result will be it goes back to the
elected legislatures and by the way
these loons that are harassing the
justices can go to their state
legislature and that will already be in
front of the legislature for the rule
they want and will let democracy play
out in other words there was no right to
such a
there was no right enumerated in the
constitution and therefore it should
constitutionally be in the state's hands
if it is overturned and this draft comes
down the way we think it probably will
that will be what uh the law in every
every state will make their own law and
we'll be able to decide from there uh
senator good to see you we'll watch very
closely uh very dangerous time i think
for the institution and for judges all
across the country hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else